okay welcome back so now we're ready to
design a control law to stabilize the
inverted pendulum on a cart okay I move
the picture down here so I could have
some breathing room last time we took
the nonlinear system describing the
Lagrangian mechanics of this inverted
cart on a pendulum on a cart problem we
simulated it then we linearized about
the pendulum up position to obtain an a
matrix and the B matrix I didn't go
through all of the math but that's kind
of basic physics oh so I showed you that
there is a linearization and then we
checked that the rank of the
controllability matrix was in fact four
which means that we span all of our
state space with this controllability
subspace meaning that the system is
controllable and of course now we know
that if the system is controllable then
with full state feedback by measuring
the full state of the position and
velocity of the cart and the pendulum so
this full state then I can design this
closed-loop system so that the
eigenvalues are anywhere I want okay and
so now what we're going to use is the
place command in MATLAB so we're
literally going to say K equals place
and we're going to give it a B and we're
going to give it a vector of desired
eigen values I okay and so let's do this
we knew that this system if I just look
at the eye of a we know that there's
this unstable eigen value so let's just
manually say I want my eigen values to
be like negative 1 negative 1 point 1
negative 1 point 2 and negative 1 point
3 so let's say i
negative 1 point 1 negative 1 point 2
negative 1 point 3 and negative 1 point
4 so my desired eigen values I want to
cook up a K so that my closed-loop
system has those eigen values ok and
this
seems like a lot to ask right I just
pulled these out of a hat they're stable
eigenvalues should be great and hit
enter okay so those are my eggs and now
I'm going to type in K equals place a be
eggs it's that simple in MATLAB it is so
simple to cook up a controller k so that
it has the poles the eigenvalues where
you want them to be so that's my
controller K it's just a matrix and now
if I look at eggs of a minus B times K
and I'm hoping that it's minus K and not
plus K we'll try this I of a minus B
times K low and behold I get exactly the
eigenvalues that I specified everyone
follow that let me just let me expand
this a little bit okay so we said I
equal this we specified the eigenvalues
we wanted and then all we did was we
said K equals place a bi X this is a
built in MATLAB function that tells me
what is the controller K in this
proportional feedback controller that
will shape the closed-loop eigenvalues
to be the eyes that I specified and this
is that K so now I just say I want to
verify that this closed-loop system does
in fact have the right eigen values so
I'm going to do a minus B times K and
the closed-loop system a minus B times K
does in fact have these desired
eigenvalues so it's really that simple
to place your eigen values where you
want with closed-loop feedback if your
system is controllable if your system
was not controllable you wouldn't be
able to do this so we get this because
our system is controllable because force
on the cart is a good control that
allows me the authority to stabilize the
pendulum okay okay excellent and so now
once we have this we can actually try
to use this K matrix so I'm just going
to type K again so we can try to use
this K gain matrix to actually stabilize
the nonlinear system which is really
going to be fun okay so I'm going to go
back to my script okay and I have a
bunch of different pull locations that
we're going to try but we're not going
to do that yet so let me just comment
those comment those out let me see if I
can remember how to do this in MATLAB
okay I'm going to comment those out and
I'm going to try a few different pole
placements a few different placements of
the eigenvalues because we're going to
play around like how where do I want to
put the eigenvalues of this closed-loop
system we're going to try a bunch of
different ones but for now let's just
try this one minus 0.3 minus 0.4 minus
0.5 minus point six more or less I'm
just pulling it out of a hat okay so I
do this place k equals place a be P
where P is my list of eigenvalues and
then I'm going to essentially integrate
the same vector field that same cart
penned vector field except in the U
position where the control is before I
had 0 I had zero control now I'm going
to plug in minus K times my state - a
reference value okay and so basically
what I want is why my state so I'm I
don't know why but I'm calling this I'm
calling this a vector Y and D DT of this
is y of f of Y and all of these become
wise whatever in MATLAB what I want is
for my state I want this to approach a
reference value of 1 0 PI 0
okay and so what that means is I want
this thing to walk over 2x equals 1 and
keep the pendulum in the vertical
position and with that K gain matrix I
should be able to do this because I've
stabilized my system okay so let's try
this out and again I can just run this
code so I am trying to move this up and
at the end of my code I'm going to draw
the solution so once I run the
simulation I'm going to plot the
pendulum doing what I want it to do okay
so let's do pull place cart pets that's
my script I'm going to hit enter I'm
going to hope for the best
oh it went off the screen but then it
came back okay so let's see if I can do
better I think I need to integrate for
longer try this one more time it's not
the most impressive okay so it starts
vertical that a little ways off it
actually goes off screen but then it
very slowly comes back to where I told
it this reference value of 1 in the
exposition zero velocity PI in the
vertical in the theta Direction zero
velocity so this pole placement did
stabilize and move the system over which
is pretty cool
okay so it actually worked but it took
forever to walk over there
and I started in an initial condition I
think it x equals minus 4 or something
like that looks let's see yeah so my
initial condition was X was minus 3 and
it was a little bit off vertical PI plus
point 1 so let's say I want to make this
more aggressive I want to make it faster
to move over to the right so what would
I do to these poles these eigenvalues i
call them poles we people call them
poles or eigenvalues they're the same
thing what would I do to these to make
them faster so this thing is more
aggressive well I could move them
farther into the left half plane I can
make them have a more negative real part
that should make them fast
Derr and more aggressive so let's try
this one okay so I'm just making them
more negative negative 1 negative 1
point 1 negative 1 point 2 negative 1
point 3 so this is more aggressive
eigenvalue placement I should have
faster faster convergence let's try this
out pole place cart pen
who's going to run very fast and it goes
right where it's supposed to so it
didn't go off screen it didn't barely
control it
did its control pretty fast which is
nice that's what we wanted to do so
moving the eigenvalues into the left
half-plane
farther seemed to be a good thing okay
now could we just keep doing this
indefinitely what if we do what if we
make them more stable okay so here I'm
going to make you know minus 2 minus 2
point 1 and so on and so forth so
disease or even more aggressive let's
try this
maybe this will just go right to the
point and be good okay really fast okay
didn't take any time getting there it
was very aggressive but you can also see
it started getting pretty jerky right
it's probably pretty expensive it's
really cranking on these these tires to
get this thing moving over there so if I
don't have a big engine or big motor in
here I might not be able to realize this
controller I'm assuming if I plotted you
to be really big okay because those
things really Hollen and I can go even
farther I can go even farther let's keep
going one more one more level of
aggressive so I'm moving it even farther
into the left half-plane and I'm going
to decrease my time I don't need to
integrate 230 any more
you can see super jerky okay and I'm not
going to show you this but if I increase
if I move those pulled any farther into
the left half-plane the system actually
breaks it becomes unstable the nonlinear
dynamics are unstable if I move my pole
of the linearized system too far into
the left half plane so it's interesting
actually we think of the eigenvalues
being farther in the left half plane
having a more negative real part as
being more stable what that really means
is it's faster those dynamics are faster
this thing will approach its desired
equilibrium faster but it's actually
less robust the farther I push these
eigenvalues into the left half plane in
a lot of cases in this case it becomes
less robust we're kind of on this nice
edge where we're really throwing the
system around and these non-linear the
nonlinear system might not act exactly
like the linear system where we built
our controller and so it's some super
aggressive control it'll actually break
and so there it turns out there's a
sweet spot an ideal set of eigenvalues
that we can place for this system that
will have the best trade-off of
performance of how fast the system moves
to where it wants to move and not
spending too much control effort in
doing so okay and so that's what we're
going to work on next it's called the
linear quadratic regulator okay this is
lqr and it's one of the most important
results in optimal control theory it's
essentially gives you the optimal gain
matrix K that balances how fast you
stabilize your state and how much
control energy you're expending to do so
so it's kind of a sweet spot of pole
placements and again in MATLAB super
simple one-line and MATLAB code okay so
that's where we're going next